[Musique]
c'est quoi ça
c'est quoi cette blague d'un mec tu une
femme plutôt du genre à faire flipper
l'un de ceux qu'il incombe leur
propre à l'estuaire si on l'a appelé
pour se venger de thouars
clk poursuit farine franchement amélie
je prends vraiment a réussi a invoqué un
fantôme de ta salle de bain je te reçois
voulait voir inscrits non ça va
proment toujours mais c'est une
coïncidence là on a un problème les
chacals lorsqu'on évoque elle exige que
ces vies d'hommes concerts
débats remis
à tous peur
il ya deux façons de stopper sa
malédiction dans la première c'est
d'appeler le démonte d'invoquer de
l'exercice
la seconde se
sait quoi la 2d
[Musique]